قال مصدر في الجيش السوداني للجزيره قوات
الدعم السريع ادخلت ناقلات جند الى
الخرطوم من دون علم الجيش بدواعي ذلك كما
اكد مصدر اخر ان قوات الدعم السريع لم
تنسحب من محيط المطار مروي رغم مطالبه
الجيش بانسحابها من جانب الاخر اكلت قوات
الدعم السريعه ان جميع التحركاتها تتم
بالتنسيق مع الجيش بينما دعت قوى سياسيه
ومدنيه لتغذيب صوت العقل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه ما هي خلفيته الازمه الحاليه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وما هي
الاسباب التي دفعت بها الى الواجهه مجددا
وما هي التاثيرات المحتمله لهذه الازمه
على المشهد السياسي في السودان وعلى
استكمال اتفاق نقل السلطه الموقع مع القوه
المدنيه وكيف تنظر تلك القوه لهذه الاسلحه
وما هي فرص احتواء الازمه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في ضوء دعوه اطراف سياسيه
لتغليف لغه الحوار للحيلوله دون انزلاق
الاوضاع الى مواجهه مباشره بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
على خلفيه توتر انحصر طوال نحو شهرين في
مستوى التصريحاتي والتباحث داخل الغرف
المغلقه خرج الخلاف بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان الى العالم مع اعلان
الجيش نشر قوات الدعم السريع ما سماها
قوات ضخمه في محيط مطار مدينه مروي في
شمال السودان يوم الاربعاء تشمل ناقلات
جند وسيارات مزوده بمدافع دون علم الجيش
او التنسيق معه وعلى خلفيه التحرك الذي
اكده لاحقا بيان للجيش اكد ايضا ان
البلاده تمر بمنعطف خطير اضاف المصدر ان
الجيش استدعى قوات من مناطق اخرى لمواجهه
الموقف وطالب قوات الدعم السريع بالانسحاب
من مروي في غضون 24 ساعه وانها ان لم تفعل
فسوف تجبر على ذلك
مصدر اخر في الجيش قال للجزيره ان قوات
الدعم السريع ادخلت الخميس ناقله جند الى
العاصمه الخرطوم قادمه من دارفور وان
الجيش لا يعلم ما هي دواعي نشر هذه
العربات
قوه الدعم السريع وفي المقابل قالت
الاربعاء عبر بيان من مكتب الناطق الرسمي
باسمها ان بعض وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تناقلت ما سماها البيان مزاعم بان قوات
الدعم السريع قامت باعمال الحربيه تجاه
مطار مروي واوضح المكتب ان قوات الدعم
السريع قوات قوميه تعمل في اطار القانون
بتنسيق وتناغم تام مع قياده القوات
المسلحه وبقيه القوات النظاميه الاخرى
اضاف البيان ان وجود قوات الدعم السريع في
الولايات الشماليه وفي مدينه مروي ياتي
ضمن وجودها في بقيه الولايات في اطار
تاديه مهامها وواجباتها التي تمتد حتى
الصحراء
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
الخرطوم كله من اللواء المتقاعد بدر الدين
عبد الحكم الباحث السابق في الاكاديميه
العليا للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامنيه
ومن الخرطوم ايضا الدكتور محمد المختار
الخبير القانونيه ومن الخرطوم كذلك عبد
الحليم تيمان مساعد رئيس حزب الامه القومي
سينضم الينا لاحقا اذا نبدا بمحمد الدكتور
محمد المختار الخبير
القانوني فيما يتعلق بتحركات الدعم السريع
ما الذي جد عليها ما الذي جد على هذه
التحركات بحيث يعتبر الجيش ان البلاد في
منعطف خطير
دعني اولا ان ارحب بك وارحب بضيفك الكريم
لا جديد هنالك هو قوات الدعم السريع
بطبيعتها هي منفتحه في كل ارجاء السودان
وان وجودها في منطقه الشماليه او ولايه
الشماليه وجود قديم في ربوع الوطن وواحده
احدى المناطق التي يعني انفتحت فيها قوات
الدعم السريع من نذو نشاتها الاولى في
منطقه المثلث وفي بعض المناطق في ولايه
نهر النيل
ووجودها كذلك في الخرطوم هو ليس وجود حديث
وجودها منذ
نشاتها وحتى ثوره 19 ديسمبر هي كانت
موجوده وامنت السوار وكانت محيطه بالسوره
القياده حول السوار وكانت في حمايه الصور
قوات الدعم السريع حسب ورد في بيان قوات
المسلحه او قاده قوات الجيش ان وجود الدعم
السريع ليس وجودا حديثا في العاصمه وليس
وجودا حديث في في الولايه الشماليه
فوجودها هو وجود طبيعي ووفقا لخطتها
وانفتاحها في اطار حفظ الامن وفي اطار
مهامها الموكله اليها وفقا لقانونها التي
انشات بموجبه في عمليه حفظ الامن وكذلك في
عمليه مكافحه الارهاب وكذلك في عمليه
القفل الحدود فيما يتعلق بعمليه الاتجار
والبشر وغيرها فافتكر انه
قوات الدعم السريع انفتاح هذه انفتاح
طبيعي
ووفقا لمعلومات الشخصيه ان حتى القوه
الاخيره التي ذهبت الى منطقه مروي كان
بعلم القوات المسلحه وبعلم قائد القوات
قائد الاعلى القوات المسلحه ولا اعتقد ان
هنالك يعني اي يعني
تجاوز لقانونها ولا اي تجاوز لمهامها
المنصوص عليها في قانونها
اذن كلها تحركات طبيعيه كما تقول الدعم
السريع وانها بعلم الجيش وقائد الجيش
والقائد الاعلى للجيش وهو
عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده
اللواء بدر الدين عبد الحكم اذا كان كل
شيء كل هذه التحركات لا تزيد عن التحركات
الاعتياديه التي تقوم بها الدعم السريع ما
وجه خشيه الجيش وتصريحه بان الامور دخلت
منعطف خطير وان هناك قوه ضخمه وانها تمت
بغير علم الجيش لدواعي ذلك يعني هل هل كل
تحرك للدعم السريع في المرحله الماضيه كان
يتم باخطار مسبق من الجيش
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحيه لكم في
قناه الجزيره
للاخ المشارك في الخرطوم والتحيه للامه
الاسلاميه برمضان الكريم اولا يعني القوات
الدعم السريع هي حقيقه هو تابعه للقوات
المسلحه وانا يعني كنت في 2017 مدير دائره
المدير اداره
الامم المتحده انا ارسلتها القانون بتاع
القوات الدعم السريعي للامم المتحده
الحقيقه التحركات الدعم السريعي كلها يعني
حسب الاتفاق وحسب القانون بالاتفاق مع
القوات المسلحه لكن هذا الاتحاد التحرك
الاخير كان بغير علم لغات المسلحه والدليل
على ذلك هذا البيان الذي اصدره القوات
المسلحه والمتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه لان
الموقع الذي انشا بغير اتفاق مع القوات
المسلحه القطعه التي تم شراءها تم شراء من
مواطن عاد وتم البناء حوله
وهذا الانفتاح غير متفق عليه لان المنطقه
منطقه عسكريه تابعه لغات المسلحه وهي
قاعده عسكريه وهي قاعده عسكريه في
الطائرات
الجويه الم تقل لواء بدر الدين ان الدعم
من القوات المسلحه
انا اريد ان اعرف ما هي المشكله اين هي
المشكله في تحركات الدعم
المشكله ان هذا المشكله ان هذا التحرك
الاخير الى منطقه مروي والارتكاز حول
المطار مروي كان بغير اتفاق مع القوات
المسلحه والدليل على ذلك هذا البيان الذي
اصدرته القياده العامه لغات المسلحه بانه
هذا التحرك وانه انه البلاد على شفاء حرب
بين القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع عشان
كده اي حديث اي حديث عن ان وجود الدعم
السريع حول حول مطار ملوي كان قديم قديما
هذا حديث غير دقيق وانه هذا هذا الوجود
كان قبل 24 ساعه فقط
نرحب ايضا بضيفنا من الخرطوم عبد الحليم
تيمان مساعد رئيس حزب الامه القومي برايك
لماذا ظهر هذا الخلاف طبعا كان هنالك خلاف
في الجلسات المغلقه في جلسات الحوار في
الورش التي كان يفترض ان تنتهي
بالتوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي لكن كان
هنالك خلاف واضح بين الدعم السريع
ووجهت نظرها فيما يتعلق بالدمج مع الجيش
وبين وجهه نظر الجيش ما الذي ادعى بهذا
الخلاف ان يخرج من هذه الغرف المغلقه الى
هذا الحشد في الشارع حشد عسكري في الخرطوم
في مروي بحسب بيانات الدعم السريع وبيانات
الجيش
التحيه لك وتحيه للساده المشاهدين ولضيوفك
الكرام
كلنا نعلم ان الدعم السريع كغيره من من
التموينات العسكريه الحكم البايت قد
استعان بمجموعات عبر التاريخ في حربها في
الجنوب وفي الغرب بمجموعات
وتكوينات عسكريه خارج اطار للقوات المسلحه
وكلكم تتذكرون قوات بيتر جديد وفاولن وحرس
الحدود والدعم السريع وما الى ذلك لكن هذه
القوه بالذات الدعم السريع وجدت حظها في
اطار تقنين وبالتالي اصبح لها قانون
وبالتالي الحديث الان الواقع قانوني
ودستوري بالنسبه لهذه القوات هذا ما
يجعلها ذات خصوصيه لكن هي ليست جزء من
القوات المسلحه عند تكوينها ولكن بعد سقوط
النظام نحن كقوه سياسيه كان علينا بعد
اقتلاع على النظام اقامه تاسيس مؤسسي
واصلاح للدوله بعد الخراب الذي قام به
الحكم البايض ووجود جيشين بهذا الشكل
لاحدى افرازات الحكم البارد وبالتالي هذه
عمليه تحتاج الى اصلاح تحتاج الى عمل
مشترك وفي ذلك نحن اطلقنا عمليه سياسيه
نحن نعلم خطوره وجود
جيشين وهذا كما ذكرت من تركه النظام
البائد وبالتالي كان لابد من اصلاح هذه
المؤسسه
بما انكم طرحتم مبادره ما هو فهمكم
ما هو فهمكم لطبيعه الخلاف الان
يعني ما هي قراءتكم لما يجري لماذا يجري
الان ما يجري لماذا يصرح الجيش بمثل هذه
التصريحات وتصرح الدعم السريع
اولا الدعم السريعي طبعا كان قانون الدعم
السريع يتكون من 25 ماده والان هناك ماده
تم حذفها اللي هو الماده خمسه الماده خمسه
تم حذفها في 2019 وهذه الماده كانت تتحدث
عن تبعيه قوات الدعم السري للقائد العام
هذه الماده تم الغاءها وبالتالي الدعم
السريع الان يتمسك
بمبدا انه الان لا يتبع للقائد العام
وبالتالي الدعم السريع تحدث عن
تكوين او الاتفاق حول رؤيه مشتركه للاداره
والسيطره وكذلك عمليه الدمج وهذه عمليه
تاتي في اطار عمليه اصلاح كامل للمؤسسه
العسكريه نحن نراها كذلك وبالتالي نحن
نعتقد ان المطلوب الان نحن نتعامل مع
عواقي كما ذكرت واقع له يعني مرجعيه
دستوريه وقانونيه وبالتالي نحن نحتاج هنا
الى عمليه
عمل المشترك بحيث ان الاصلاح يتم على يعني
اكمل وجه وان يبتعدوا عن تعريض البلاد
لمزيد من الاخطار لانه نحن نعلم ان يعني
السودان بلد ورث هشاشه في كل المؤسسات
وبالتالي
الاحتقان عاده من الممكن ان تبدا الحرب
بطلقه او
بخطا فردي وبالتالي طلقه ثم صاروخ ثم
طائره ثم دبابه وبالتالي عليه ان يعو
تماما ان الاحتقان ايضا
يعني فيه احتمال لبعض الاخطاء التي ممكن
ان تعرض البلاد للخطر نحن نحدد ربط النفس
نحن نعتقد اننا جميعا
اعود الى اللواء بدر الدين عبد الحكم مره
اخرى
ضيفنا الاستاذ عبد الحليم اوضح ما تفضلت
بذكره سابقا وهو قانون الدعم السريع الذي
تقول انك كنت طرفا فيه قانون الدعم السريع
الذي كان ينص على تبعيتها للقوات المسلحه
وللجيش ولقائد الجيش الفقره الماده
الخامسه منه من الذي لغاها من الذي الغى
هذه الماده هو رئيس مجلس السياده الحالي
عبد الفتاح البرهان القائد الاعلى للجيش
وذلك حينما كانت الامور على ما يرام بين
الطرفين ما الذي حدا بالامور ان تصل الى
هذه المرحله الان كانت الامور تبدو ان
الطرفين في كل شيء ما الذي جرى ما الذي جد
حتى 2017
وحتى انه رفعنا القانون الذي اجازه
الحكومه السودانيه وتم ارساله الى الامم
المتحده بانه الماده الخامسه فيه وكانت
تتحدث بانه الدعم السريع تابع
للوطن المسلحه وحتى الان كل لغات المسلحه
وكل حتى الغايه قوات الدعم السريه تحدث
بانه
اللواء بدر الدين عايز
الفتره لا يوجد لا يوجد
لا يوجد برلمان ان يلغي هذه الماده لان
هذه الماده وضعت بواسطه البرلمان في فتره
الانقاذ الوطني فكيف انه يتم الغاء
يعني
هل هو الغاء باطل
يسال يسال غايه الدعم السريع والاداره
القانونيه من الغى هذه الماده حتى الان
هذه الغائها
والله ما في ما في دليل على انه البرهان
لانه الان الخلاف حول اذا اصل الغيت فكيف
كيف يتم دمج الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه الان يعني
هل تقول ان هذه الماده التي الغت تبعيت
الدعم السريع للقوات المسلحه لم تلغى وهي
قائمه
انا بعلمي حتى 2017 عندما رفعت هذه رفعت
هذا القانون ان الماده دي موجوده اذا كان
علمك يتوقع
فان ما حدث من امر الالغاء انما حدث في
عام 2019 فيوليو 2019 في بيان صادر عن
القوات المسلحه حتى الان تعتبر وتدعم
السريع تابع له لان التسليحه تسليح الدعم
السريع ومرتبات عساكر ضباط الدعم السريع
ولكل العمليات اللوجستيه تؤخذ من الغوات
المسلحه فكيف اذا الغيت هذه الماده كيف
انه انه هذه الاشياء كلها الى ذلك
للتوضيح ايضا الواء بدر الدين القوات
المسلحه لم تعترض على هذا الالغاء لكن
دعنا نتوجه الى ضيفنا ايضا من الخرطوم
السيد الدكتور محمد المختار وهو خبير
قانوني ما خصوصيه مروي يعني لماذا كل هذه
يعني التصريحات والتصريحات المضاده
خرجت بعد انتشار تقول انه طبيعي لقوات
الدعم السريع في قاعده عند مطار مروي
تحديدا لماذا مروي تحديدا ما هي خصوصيتها
دعني قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال ان اوضح
بعض المعلومات بشان قانون قوات الدعم
السريع والماده خمسه ان الماده خمسه التي
تحدث عنها ضيفك الكريم والذي قال يعني تم
الغائها ليس الماده المتعلقه بتبعيه قوات
الدعم السريع للقائد
العام للقوات المسلحه هي الماده المتعلقه
بدمج قوات الدعم السريع في قوات في القوات
المسلحه وهذه الماده تم الغائها في عام
2019 من المجلس العسكري ووقع عليه البرهان
والان لا يوجد اي نص يتحدث عن دمج قوات
الدعم السريع خالص وقوات الدعم السريع
منشئه بموجب قانون مثله مثل قانون قوات
الشعب المسلحه مثله مثل قانون جهاز الامن
المخابرات مثله مثل قانون الشرطه فاعتقد
ان ضيفك الكريم
الان ووفقا للاتفاق الاطار التي تم
التوقيع عليه بين قوات الدعم بين الاطراف
الموقعه على الاعلان السياسي وكذلك الجيش
والد السريع انه تبعيه القوات المسلحه
والتبعيه قوات الدعم السريع الى راس
الدوله المدني الذي ياتي بعد التوقيع
النهائي على هذا الاتفاق اما خصوصيه منطقه
مروي مروي هي يعني جزء من المناطق
السودانيه ومنطقه طبعا يعني هي في وسط في
في شمال السودان واعتقد ان ليس لها خصوصيه
عن بقيه مناطق السودان الاخرى ولكن تمركز
القوات موجود فيها يعني
الاعتبارات اعتقد انها متعلقه القوميه
عذرا دكتور بيان الجيش يتحدث عن وجود ضخم
لقوات الدعم السريع وناقلات جند
ومدرعات ثقيله عند مروي وايضا ارسال
ناقلات جند الى الخرطوم ما الداعي لذلك
وجود قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وجود
تقليدي ووجود قديم ليس هو وجود حديث فيما
وجودها فيما يروي قد يكون تم في وقت قصير
اللي هو تقريبا له يومين او ثلاثه ايام
وهذا الوجود اعتقد انه وجود طبيعي بناء
على انفتاح القوى وكذلك بناء على خطه
الامنيه في حفظ الامن وكذلك خطتها في
عمليه مكافحه الارهاب وكذلك عاملين في
مكافحه الاتجار وبشر والمخدرات وغيرها
فاعتقد انه وجودها هناك انا اعتقد انه
يمكن ان يكون هو عمليه يعني ازعج القوات
المسلحه ولكن هذا اعتقد انه غير صحيح
فوجودها في الخرطوم هو النفسي وجودها كذلك
في منطقه مروي ونفسه وجودها في بورسودان
نفسه وجودها في بقيه بقاع السودان يعني
ولماذا وجودها في مروي الان هو يشكل مشكله
واذا افترضنا جدلا ان هذه القوات ذهبت دون
علم القوات المسلحه ودون علم القائد
الاعلى القوات المسلحه هل هذا يمكن ان
يكون مدعاه لهذا البيان التي يمكن ان ينبئ
بحرف المستقبل طيب
اعتقد ان هذه ليس المشكله الاساسيه لعمليه
التصريحات او عمليه البيان بتعديل يجب ان
يشخص المشكله بوضعها الطبيعي ووضع الحروب
على النقاط استاذ عبد الحليم يعني بين
الجيش يتحدث عن انه اذا لم تنسحب قوه
الدعم السريع من مروي فانه سيجبرها على
ذلك هل نحن امام السيناريو فعلا يمكن ان
تتقاتل في اكبر قوتين عسكريتين في السودان
الجيش والدعم السريع
ايضا نعود الى الماده خمسه قبل ان اجيب
على هذا السؤال صحيح ان الماده خمسه طبعا
تتحدث ان دمج الدعم السريع في الجيش هذه
الماده الغيت وبالتالي الدعم السريع صار
له وضع كجيش منفصل وهذا هذا هو الواقع
الجيشين الذي يتحدث عنه ولكن الاتفاق
الاطاري طبعا هناك اتفاق على مستوى الاسس
والمبادئ تم التوقيع عليه يتحدث ايضا عن
تبعيه قوات الدعم السريع الى راس الدوله
الذي لم ياتي الى الان وبالتالي الشيء
الطبيعي الان القانون الذي هو يسري تبعيه
الدعم السريع للقوات المسلحه او القاعده
الاعلى هذا هو الوضع حتى تنفيذ الاتفاق
الايطالي لكن بالنظر الى التوتر الموجود
طبعا من المفروض ان يتم كل امر بتنسيق
يعني وخروج الامر ان يعني من خلال
الادارات المشتركه الى البيانات الى الشعب
هذا امر التطور خطير جدا جدا هل يمكن طبعا
هناك ملاحظه مهمه
توجد دوله يعني لا غياب غياب الغياب
القياده السياسيه في الدوله هذا ما يؤدي
الى مثل هذه الاشياء كل الجيوش في العالم
بتراسها قيادات سياسيه وغياب القياده
السياسيه والركود السياسي وعدم الوصول الى
الاتفاق جعل هذا الوضع وضع خطير جدا ونحن
ننبه انه هناك ضروره لقياده سياسيه
لتولي زمام الامر يعني عدم ترك الامور في
ظل هذا الوضع الخطير جدا
هل هو قابل للاحتواء اولا ثانيا ما مصير
الاتفاق السياسي اذا
الاتفاق السياسي طبعا يتعرض لصعوبات كثيره
وتعلمون طبعا هناك اجندات مختلفه وهناك
جهات تعمل من اجل تعطيل هذا الاتفاق لكن
نحن املنا كبير جدا في وعي الشعب
والتكوينات السياسيه ونحن نستشعر كل
المهددات والخطر وسنعمل
بكل ما اوتينا من قوه من اجل ان نصل الى
اتفاق ولكن يظل هذا الوضع خطير جدا وطبعا
تعلم التجارب الانسانيه في الدول التي
سبقتنا في الانتقال السياسي هناك دول
عندما يصلون الى مرحله الخلافه السياسي
عدم الوصول الى التفاعل السياسي هو مؤشر
خطير وهي مرحله ما قبل الانزلاق نحو
الحروب كما حدث في اليمن مثلا كان هناك
مائده مستديره كانت هناك موحدسات جيده كان
هناك هبوط زي ما يعني كما يقولون هبوط
نائم نائب الرئيس جاء وكانت هناك حكومه
وبالتالي اختلف الناس فيما بينهم فانزلقت
البلاد نحو الحروب فاذا المطلوب هو
الاتفاق السياسي شكرا جزيلا استاذ عبد
الحليم مساعد رئيس حزب الامه القومي ونشكر
ايضا من الخرطوم الدكتور محمد المختار
الخبير القانوني ومن الخرطوم كذلك اللواء
المتقاعد بدر الدين عبد الحكم الباحث
السياسي في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه
لهنا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]